good news
every pen is taken care of
bad news
you guys are wrong about tj oh i'm
really not loving this routine yeah well
janae and i just went through his phone
and the entire time that tj was
suspended he was either surfing getting
in and out or at home youtubing doomsday
prepper videos
the point is he wasn't stalking addy at
the waterpark and he was miles away from
the movie theater when someone else took
a picture of you guys so the killer's
still out there yeah it's great because
that went nowhere and i made myself a
target tonight for nothing hey
that wasn't for nothing
that was for simon
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
very very much
oh [ __ ] you still alive
rumors of my deaths have been greatly
exaggerated
oh
what am i supposed to do with this thing
hmm funeral cake you shouldn't have
[Music]
do you remember that pact who nini made
with his wife
whoever died first had to contact the
other from the grave yes and nothing
ever came because ghosts have better
things to do
it just got me thinking about you know
things i might
never get to say to you or um
some things i may be sort of uh
regret i get it
i do
you're apologizing to me
no no thrilling no hold on not an
apology um
more of an update
i know i've been distant lately
so i'm gonna back off from maeve
now i've got enough on my plate with ap
classes and and college applications
she's just a distraction so it's not
about maeve
you [ __ ] know that
you're gonna make me say it yeah
i was a bad friend
and i'm sorry
i love you
sure
really
sure what give me something
same
what
[Music]
janae
[Music]
leave me please i can't please stop
showing up for me okay
okay fine i'll go
i hate most people i hate pretty much
everyone i'm really good at it and i
don't hate you
i think you're fascinating
can you make me smile and you're
the like person i've ever met
and it's not even annoying that you keep
showing up but i want to be alone but i
i really need you to stop because every
time you do
every time i do what
i like you
so i just i really would appreciate it
if you could stay away from me
[Music]
why did she do that
because i wanted to
[Music]
so
[Music]
you